john de plainier goes for the
diamondbacks and on two records it's his
fourth start this season his last
timeout wasn't too bad against oakland
here's jared walsh now the first baseman
hitting 291 with 13 overs 40 driven in
next pitch is grounded to the right side
diving play escobar's got it from his
knee throws to first and they got him at
first base on a dandy play by escobar
who went far to his left he's a little
slow in getting up but a pretty good
play there it's nasty two for six in the
series with a run batted in hitting 345
this season his offense has certainly
been
a surprise and
he has been moving up in the batting
order as a result
so he's ready with another 3-2 on stassi
it's on its way swings at that one and
lifts this ball high and he hits it deep
out in the left-center field and that
one is out of here
max dassey has homered well you were
just talking about his problems with the
home run ball speaking of duponte and
the angels third batter of the game
makes it two nothing patrick sandoval is
going to try to get his first victory as
a starter the angels left the owen two
this year but a three point six two er
kelly is hitting 260 one for six in the
series but just three for his last
23.
change up swung on and missed another
swing and miss down he goes
and here's patrick sandoval
a couple of years ago he had a couple of
at bats inter league cincinnati was over
two
how about a little bit
of slash
ernest on first and third
showed bunt pulled the bat back patrick
sandoval first big league hit and now
the banner david fletcher is over the
series thus far
duplantiers pitch and there is a bun
push button on the right side the flip
to the catcher and the ball's mishandled
never even got a tag down anyway and
that is going to be a
squeeze bunt and the angels lead it
three nothing
here's upton again next pitch on upton
he swings to that one lines one into
left center field that's going to drop
in sandoval will be waived home he will
score they're also waving home fletcher
he will score
and the angels already have a
five-nothing lead here in the second
walsh grounded out and the angels
hitters pitchers have done well here's
walsh hitting one down the right side
and that's a fair ball it's gonna bounce
all the way out to the wall just
retrieving it is riddick coming in will
be upped and he'll score and the angels
just keep adding on it's now six nothing
iglesias tap back to the mound his first
time up
looks back at second comes center the
letters
and the next one on the way to iglesias
is grounded to second base
escobar's got it he fires to first to
walker and that will end the inning nine
go to the plate for the angels they get
a total of four in the ending and they
will leave a pair we'll go to the bottom
of the second six nothing halos
as drubal cabrera
262 batting average so far this season
veteran infielder 35 years old
and sandoval's next delivery and there's
a swing and a miss he got cabrera to
chase a change up that was blowing out
of the strike zone got him swinging
he'll bring up pavon smith who lined out
durandon his first event now you can
make this really interesting with the
long ball here
got the lead in half
or even a gapper right here and get it
to redick next
runner's lead walker and cabrera at a
line drive base in left fail that'll
produce a run dimeback's on the board
second time pavement smith has gone the
other way this one he got by
the lunging anthony rendon into left
field for an rbi single it's 6-1
so the batter now is riddick
here's the delivery and this is a little
chopper that's over the mound it's
fielded there by iglesias with the shift
on he will throw to first and gets the
final out the 6-3 ground out retires
riddick but they got a run in the inning
and they
had three singles in the inning they
also leave the pair on
yeah they're still going to let riley
smith bad and why not he's been pitching
outstanding for them there's a pitch
that riley smith on an o2 delivery
chases and he is a strikeout victim
and now the batter will be lagaris
here's the pitch and that's a ball lying
down the left side and that's to roll
down in the corner just getting to it is
paving smith that is easily going to
bring in ward and at second base
back-to-back doubles laguaris is there
angels extend the lead it's now 7-1
here's david fletcher
here's the next pitch and that's a
little shot down the left side that's
another ball it's going to drop in just
getting to it is paving smith that will
bring in a run fletcher is going to stop
at second angels third double in the
inning
and you can hear the reaction from the
crowd at chase field the angels now have
an eight one lead
stance he's got a tour on armor he's
walked and struck out in the ball game
swinging a fly ball into right
and right there is redick he's got him
the sides retired
so the angels in the inning get a couple
here's cattell martay
swung right through it
martay goes down that swing and miss
change-up escobar will be the next
spatter
the d-backs one run four hits one error
here's the next pitch this ball is
lifted high in the air it's hit deep out
into center field and jumping up and
making the grab out on the warning track
right near the wall is juan logaris that
was a real good play by the angel center
fielder david peralta going to come off
the bench and pinch it for nick nick was
over two two ground ball outs to third
and peralta rolls it into center
make it eight to two
two outs in the inning carson kelly the
next batter
here's the next delivery this is lifted
in the air down the right side chasing
after making the running catch towards
the line in right field is taylor ward
and that is how the inning will end so
they do get a run
here's jared walsh
and here's the pitch this is a ball that
he lifts high and deep out into right
center field and that ball is way out of
here
boy he hit it out in right center he
cleared the
area where they have the swimming pool
there
and connects with a two-run homer that
is his 14th home run of the season the
angels add on and now it is 10-2 angels
they have runners at the corners now
with one out
and cabrera will be the next batter
and here's the pitch let's hit sharply
on the first base side walsh has it goes
to second for one relay back to first
and that is a double play
and that is how the inning will end
and kelly will be the getter over four
today
slide to left field to base hit here
comes the runner around third there'll
be no throw by upton
so with two outs a single walk in an rbi
single to make this score 10 to three
so the batter is lo castro and he will
dig in
here comes the next pitch he swings at
that one hits it sharply to rendon this
should do it flip to second base and
that is how the ball game ends fielder's
choice will wrap it up